in this massive emphasis on marriage  when really it doesn't well i think the  father being in the home should be the  most important thing and so the question  is why did like if she was married and  that happened my question would be why  did it end because 70 to 80 of the time  women leave why did you leave why did  you why'd you put your feelings above  the kids that's an assumption that's an  assumption no it's based off of data  statistics so it's based off of data if  you're college educated the chance that  you get divor like you leave is 90 the  chance that you leave a marriage yeah  as a woman if you're college  if you're college educated it's 90 and  70 to 80  so women leave much more than men do  it's not an assumption it's based on  data